hello in this video we're going to talk
about how fat gets burned okay now when
you think about fat burning there's no
real burning going on it's basically the
release of fat from the fat cell that
gets turned into energy okay I'm going
to just talk about the mechanics of
actually what happens your fat cell is
primarily stored with triglycerides
okay those are fats and they're in a liquid
state so your fat is basically liquid
it's not a solid and what happens is
that there's an enzyme called hormone
sensitive lipase it's an enzyme now
enzymes are proteins that help chemical
changes occur in the body they're like
the workhorse they're like the worker
bee that does the work in the body
they're kind of magical because they can
go in there and change and break down
proteins and build them back up break
down fat and build and back up into body
tissue so lipase is the primary enzyme
that releases the stored fat in the fat
cell and it's a hormone sensitive which
means it's triggered by certain hormone
okay so now that we know that lipase is
the enzyme now the real question is what
triggers let's pace okay
there's certain things that trigger it
and number one we're going to use this
little book right here guidance
physiology on page 927 it says insulin
inhibits the action of hormone sensitive
lipase okay so if this is the burning of
fact or the releasing effect and insulin
is there it will inhibit this it will
stop it
number two insulin promotes glucose
transport into the fat cell so basically
in the presence of insulin it's going to
actually cause storage into the fat cell
okay so far insulin is not good for
losing weight right but here's what I
want talking about therefore when infant
is not available to promote glucose
entry into the fat cell that storage is
almost completely blocked okay all
aspects of fat metabolism are greatly
enhanced in the absence
of insulin okay so it's really the
absence of insulin and triggers lipase
that's the trigger
all right so cutting out the carbs not
eating so frequently those are the two
big ones
number two fasting so fasting is another
trigger for this enzyme intermittent
fasting why because every time you eat
you trigger insulin right another one
adrenaline from exercise so exercise
will trigger the lipase enzyme to help
you dissolve fat growth hormone is
another trigger for lipase growth
hormone would be intense exercise
sleeping a small amount of protein and
intermittent fasting those are all the
triggers for growth on them sigh red
hormones will also trigger lipase okay
now sometimes people will say they have
a confusion because they say well
insulin resistance is blocking insulin
from getting into the cell stair buddy
will have lower insulin and will lose
weight but that's not what happens
because when you have insulin resistance
and sends a signal to the pancreas
forcing the pancreas to make five to
seven times more insulin so insulin
resistance is actually too much insulin
because of the overcompensation that's
occuring it's a real important point
that you need to know so we have this
release of fat from the fat cell partly
we got triglycerides fatty acids that can
be used for energy in the muscle but
also a lot of it's just converted
through the liver into ketones which is
used for energy so that's where we get
the ketosis so the question is would a
low calorie diet trigger lipase okay
well not necessarily not if you have
carbs in your diet too many carbs and
you're triggering insulin so this will
just kind of help you understand like
what diets will work what diets won't
well a high-fat diet cause the release
of the fat well not necessarily because
high fat does not inhibit insulin you
can still be eating carbs and fat at the
same time
fasting well that's not eating anything
exercise growth hormone so high fat is
not the trigger it's something that you
want to consume because it's it's kind
of not going to trigger insulin too much
but it's not the main trigger low fat
diet is is that going to help trigger
the release of this no because there is
no when you do a low fat diet that's not
a trigger to this enzyme at all it's not
gonna help you lose weight with a
high-protein diet cause this trigger no
because high protein doesn't trigger
enemies with a vegan diet trigger lipase
no because you can be eating a lot of
carbs it really depends on your insulin
level if you're doing intimate fasting
exercise growth hormone and thyroid
hormone avoiding saturated fat is that
can help you lose weight no it's not
going to help you lose weight at all so
the point is that this is how fast burn
through this enzyme these are the
triggers and that's the simplicity of it
thanks for watching
hey if you haven't already subscribed
press this little button down below okay
thanks